we are here with Sam Shanklin after a
comfortable draw against Wesley so Sam
welcome to the studio tell us a bit
about your trip to Berlin you just came
back from Berlin where you actually met
Wesley in the finals yeah so uh
definitely that match probably gave him
more confidence coming into this one
than it gave me but yeah it was fun to
play Blitz there I I've always focused
so much more on classical chess than
Blitz in any way and I definitely that's
you know in classical chess I'm really
one of the best players in the world
named Blitz not so much but I was very
happy that in Berlin I finished in
second place so yeah I got a bunch of
really strong guys and uh managed to
beat the streamers who always crushed me
online so uh yeah getting to play over
the board felt good but yeah glad to be
back here now how do you change that
training routine because we know you
focus a lot on very difficult problems
where you get to spend a lot of time and
find the solution how do you change your
training not just that I mean I also go
deep into like Rook end games I've just
finished first draft of my book
theoretical real kind games which is an
absolute Behemoth and I go deep opening
preparation too I mean Blitz basically
you just have to play a whole ton of
games and you have to be born talented
while classical it's a bit more fair and
that you put in the hours you're going
to get better
um but yeah I just you know play a
little bit more Blitz and I mean it's
still definitely not my main focus or
anything but yeah I'm very glad to be
playing classical chess again I haven't
played since us championship and glad to
get invited to turn on here I'll throw
you a curveball what do you think of
this end game
between Hikaru and Sam Seville speaking
of rook and games very likely I draw I
think I mean white we won one Pawn but I
don't think you're gonna win this game
like
for example if you do something like say
B3 which because I don't know what else
B3 right yeah okay after cb3 ab3 Rook B3
Rook C6 take take and King G7 and Rook
S6 actually it's significantly easier to
draw this with black with the fractured
Pawn structure than it is with the
normal one although even the normal one
I can't imagine sylvian's gonna lose so
I mean if akara wants to win this game
he's not going to play B3 but I mean it
really feels like black should be
holding it
um
unless yeah unless I can somehow get his
maneuver his C7 Rook to C3 somehow which
I just don't see happening I definitely
think this should be a drawn yeah looks
very holdable to me excellent now let's
talk about your game tell us the story
of that
a very comfortable pin very quickly I
think so if you actually go back to
instead of Bishop A4 let's say he plays
the Italian let's say he plays Bishop C4
Bishop C5
uh like uh C3 Knight F6 D3 Castle
whatever
um yeah D3 castle castle I forget the
Mover doesn't matter like D6 H3 uh A6
a for there exists a move B5 in this
position I don't know if it's exactly
here but like
before then if you take oh no sorry
especially by seven first another night
the special base seven Rook at one of
them be five yes so here there there
exists rookie one there exists this move
B5 which Ari antari played with me and
the best move is probably Bishop B3 and
I think black is basically fine here
after B4 and then again I just got this
with the tempo up because he's played
Bishop B5 Bishop A4 and Bishop B3
instead of Bishop C4 Bishop B3 and even
here I thought black was basically fine
so like I got a Tempo up version of
this Italian the way we got it
uh yeah like here yeah because you're
after B4 Lake he's taking three moves to
put the bishop me through so I got this
very comfortable position pretty fast
but I tried a little too hard to make
something happen like when um when I
played D5 I think is critical like I
mean
because this is obviously a somewhat
controversial move because now if we can
see if I've gone and I was trying to to
make something happen but I think I
overestimated my position a little bit
because it got a little uncomfortable
after 85 and then it takes D5 but you're
still playing so confidently at this
point yeah like you calculated that I
was never super worried like okay for
example after rookie one Knight F4 is
played I mean it's tough it was a little
uncomfortable here but I really didn't
think it was much like Queen F4 Queen D5
and okay our Queen D7 they were instead
of Rook 81 he could have tried for
example there was D4 here for instance
which I was at least a little bit
concerned about but I thought that
basically anything was fine I think in
the game I was actually thinking even
Rook fd8 which the computer apparently
hates but uh G3 this one okay well well
I would have thought here but yeah I
mean this looked a little uncomfortable
but I didn't really see a huge problem
like it felt like babe it was basically
fine and after Queen E4 I think
basically calculated out all the way
till the end of the game and then
I saw this Knight takes C3 move because
without that it's probably a little
uncomfortable but yeah or a lot
uncomfortable yeah I'd seen this from
afar and yeah
Sam uh pretty comfortable draw tomorrow
you play with the white pieces what's
the strategy well do my best to put him
under pressure I mean Wesley is
definitely the most solid guy in this
tournament you know he's
probably not the most dangerous but he's
definitely the hardest one to beat so
you know I will do my best to put him
under pressure but you know I've I've
gotten it's very rare that I've been
able to get advantages of white against
someone I have he always holds it so it
and I'll I'll do my best but uh yeah the
hard game is behind me I guess so far so
good difficult task tomorrow good luck
thank you thank you Sam indeed uh
difficult test tomorrow all the games
are difficult jumping